I think the Labour Party general
election campaign has been a case study
in double standards one person ubben did
you did you hear an apology last night
from EDD Miliband for crashing the
economy no no you didn't know you didn't
hear you did you hear him complain to
absolute disbelief from the audience in
the television debate yesterday that the
Labour Party didn't borrow too much
money apparently but I'll tell you where
Labour's double standards are are the
worst of all it's on the NHS this is a
party that claims that it loves the NHS
but you know what you won't hear from
the Labour Party is that when they were
in office they neglected the one in four
of our fellow citizens who suffer from
mental health standards did they lift a
finger to really change mental health
provision no they didn't what you don't
hear from the Labour Party is that when
they were in charge they wasted millions
of pounds of your money on waste
wasteful private finance initiatives
they wasted 250 million pounds a quarter
of a billion pounds of your money on
sweetheart deals with a private sector
which didn't help a single NHS patient
and they have the gall they have the
double standards to lecture us about how
we should protect our NHS